it is hard to find comfortable t-shirts
shirts made of supima cotton are the
softest you will find under one percent
of t-shirts are made with supima cotton
and the Leisure of NYC is the place to
find them you'll get 15 off their silky
smooth t-shirts and boxers at
davidpackman.com
NYC the link is down below
we're going to start today with the
Supreme Court and more news of Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas's
undisclosed freebies from wealthy Pals
as Rolling Stone is calling them there's
really three stories here and we're
going to talk about all three there's
the specifics about what's happening
with Clarence Thomas there are the
broader questions of what should be done
if anything with the Supreme Court and
then there is the question of more
broadly what about 2024 now that we know
the Havoc that 2016's presidential
election has had on the Supreme Court
and as a result on the country let's
start with the specifics of Clarence
Thomas Rolling Stone reports
investigation uncovers more of Clarence
Thomas's undisclosed freebies from
wealthy Pals the Supreme Court Justices
rich friends at the Horatio Alger
Association have showered him with
Benefits including lavish vacations and
funds for a fawning documentary about
his life this is no longer the exception
to what's going on we now have so many
examples of this including of course
Harlan Crowe and what we learned some
months ago I believe it was but now we
have even more look at some of the
details Clarence Thomas's connections to
wealthy and expensive vacations run
deeper than billionaire businessman and
Nazi Enthusiast Harlan Crowe the New
York Times reports that Thomas has
milked relationships with the rich he
made through the Horatio Alger
Association of distinguished Americans
because of their Horatio Alger
connections Thomas and his spouse
Virginia have been invited to join
luxurious vacations and parties in
addition to getting VIP access to sports
events Thomas also rubbed elbows with
the likes of Oprah Winfrey and Ed
McMahon during a lavish three-day
Montana birthday party for billionaire
industrialist Dennis Washington both the
connections Thomas Made through Horatio
but the connections Thomas Made through
Horatio Alger have benefited benefited
him Beyond just lavish trips his
contacts including Washington investor
David Sokol formerly of Berkshire
Hathaway helped fund a documentary that
paints Thomas in a heroic light
um and it totally rewrites history on
the Anita Hill confirmation hearings and
there are all sorts of other examples
the gifts include flights on private
planes cigars clothing etc etc after
2004 when the LA Times reported on his
disclosures Thomas ceased reporting to
the court gifts and benefits that he
received a propublica investigation this
year uncovered his relationship with
Crow uh including private jet flights
yacht trips all of it Crow paying
tuition for Thomas's nephew who the
Thomases were raising and it goes on and
on and on and the list is exactly what
you would imagine if you're really
interested in the specific details you
can certainly read the entire reporting
but I think you sort of get the picture
so then we get to the implications and
the meaning of all of this first and
foremost we have a particular situation
where between his wife Virginia and her
involvement in the effort to overturn
2020 election results Thomas's lack of
recusal on related matters the ethical
questions that combo all of these
different things add a basic core level
we can see that the Supreme Court
doesn't actually have the checks
balances and accountability methods that
it should have this is very similar to
what we saw during Trump's presidency we
learned that the checks and balances put
in place by the framers of the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights Etc
they never accounted for someone like
Trump willing to flout all of those
conventions they just didn't and so what
we saw was that we don't have a firm or
rigid enough set of checks and balances
to control a president like Donald Trump
we just don't have it similarly we are
finding that the same applies to the
Supreme Court and so do we need some
kind of transparency and ethics reform
on the Supreme Court of course we do
ethics rules need to be strengthened
transparency requirements need to be
strengthened there need to be clearer
guidelines for recusal
stricter guidelines for disclosure of
financial interests and Gifts actual
limitations on the gifts and favors that
you're allowed to accept which could
create a conflict of interest or the
appearance of a conflict of interest we
need all of those things and this gets
us into the reform part I know that
there are some in my audience who say
Joe Biden should pack the court by
packing the court we mean adding seats
to the Supreme Court such that if you
expand the court say from 9 to 13 seats
by adding four and then immediately
select those four Supreme Court Justices
you could take control of the court in
the sense that by adding four liberal
justices you then take control back I
love the idea of taking control back the
problem I see
is that it really is opening the door to
Republicans doing the same the next time
they have a president in the white house
and then Democrats doing the same and
next thing you know we've got 17 19 21
23 seats it doesn't seem to me like
really the path forward just because
Biden can get away with it right now now
if Biden did it and we got a more
liberal Supreme Court and we got some
good decisions would I complain of
course I wouldn't complain but I
question its viability as a long-term
strategy what I would like to see in
addition to the transparency in ethics
reform I just mentioned includes term
limits on the Supreme Court I believe we
should have term limits for Supreme
Court Justices we have nine justices you
figure out the math of it figure out the
term limits figure out the Cadence and
then you know in advance instead of
wondering okay
if Trump beats Hillary he might get one
two or three justices we would know
exactly the number that the next
president would get it might make it
more concrete when we talk about the
importance of voting for the right
president based on Supreme Court
selections which I will get to in a
moment so I believe term limits would be
a great thing to do balanced
representation is also an interesting
idea I'm not talking about you need a
black woman and an Asian dude and then a
person in a wheelchair I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about
ensuring or requiring that you need a
certain number of justices from
different legal backgrounds so you could
say well you'd you must have a Justice
whose background is civil rights Public
Defense public interest law or whatever
the case may be this would widen the
perspective on the court I think that
that's a useful reform and there are
others would I be glad for Joe Biden to
add four justices and take control of
the Court sure do I think it's the
long-term solution I don't lastly let us
again remember we would not be in this
mess I mean Clarence Thomas would be on
the court but what I mean is we would
not have one of the most right-wing
courts in decades
overturning Roe v Wade making the
decisions they've made with regard to
voting rights and so many other things
if Hillary Clinton had defeated Donald
Trump in 2016 I don't say that to lay
blame I don't say that for any reason
other than there's another election
coming up in 16 months 11 and 12 16
months 15 and a half months this is
happening again
it is quite plausible that there will be
two Supreme Court nominations for
whoever wins in November of 2024 to make
during the following four years
plausible maybe even likely let's not
make that mistake from 2016 again
Gavin Newsom continues to be brutal and
ruthless in what I believe are all the
right ways he had that extraordinary
interview with Fox News propaganda Sean
Hannity which we covered he was
interviewed again this time by former
Biden press secretary Jen saki on her
MSNBC show and I want to play a
particular clip from that interview that
a number of you sent me regarding uh
mental illness and Mental Health crisis
Gavin knew some blames Fox News in this
clip
for uh making the Mental Health crisis
worse listen to what he says
I want to know your thoughts and I'll
give you mine take a listen
entertainment Wing particularly of the
Republican Party the surround sound on
Fox with these you know I don't even
like say his name Tucker Carlson or that
other I don't even the guy from I mean
it's just like they're all the same and
what American news and Newsmax and what
they're doing to divide this country to
you know we're illusion rules not facts
do you occasionally turn on Fox runtime
and see what happens just to see
occasionally um
every night every night and do you think
democrats should still be appearing on
Fox or should they not be a parent uh it
contributes to the Mental Health crisis
in the state so on the basis of one's
own personal conditions I would not
recommend it my staff is quite literally
trying to have interventions with me
about it they say I'm too obsessed with
it but I need to understand it you want
to know what the other side thinks so he
says Gavin Newsom says Fox News and
other right-wing trash media contribute
to the Mental Health crisis potentially
causing mental illness is that just a
funny line or is it actually a real
possibility well there's a number of
ways in which he may actually be on to
something there is an argument that by
exposing viewers to misinformation and
fear-mongering and fomenting
polarization based on lies and being
scared of scapegoats that they establish
that they are actually changing the
perception of reality that their viewers
have and that this thus affects their
emotional well-being and social
relationships and makes Fox viewers more
prone to anxiety depression
paranoia a potentially activating a
latent mental health issue like
schizophrenia or whatever the case may
be I'm not saying that's the case but
I'm saying is there an argument to be
made here that Gavin Newsom might be
right like for example there are studies
that have found Fox News viewers are
more likely to believe false or
unsupported claims about covid about
climate change about immigration and the
dangerous brown people that are coming
here or election fraud or whatever once
they believe those false things it can
cause confusion distrust fear and denial
of scientific realities distrust of
expert advice for example
all of those things can impact the
health including the mental health of an
individual another example Fox News will
often portray certain groups of people
on the opinion shows in particular but
on the news shows as well immigrants
Muslims liberals protesters marxists
anarchists as Donald Trump used to say
as threats enemies and criminals and
this induces fear and anger or even
hatred this increases stress levels
cortisol Etc impacts empathy fuels
aggression
this can lead to a mental health crisis
Etc so I don't have to belabor it but is
there something to what Gavin Newsom is
saying there ultimately obviously the
impact of Fox News on Mental Health
depends on a number of factors and
contextual realities and the
pre-existing mental state of those who
are watching Fox News in the first place
I'm not pretending Fox news is giving
everybody mental illness uh but by any
means but is there something to what
Gavin Newsom said let me know in a
comment let me know in an email let me
know on threads where you can find me at
david.pakman
often I have to wear shirts for a long
time before the material softens and
feels good on my skin but if you want a
t-shirt that's actually super soft right
when you open the package brand new
check out our sponsor Leisure of NYC
T-shirts from Leisure of NYC are made
with supima cotton that's an Ultra
Premium species of cotton known for
feeling better than any other t-shirt
Fabric and way more durable under one
percent of men's t-shirts are made with
supima cotton also check out the boxer
briefs made from moisture wicking
viscose from bamboo which will bring you
a level of comfort you didn't even know
was possible with underwear these boxer
briefs feel like air and they don't
Bunch up all of their products are fair
trade produced using sustainable methods
when you buy the scratchy cheaply made
t-shirts and boxers you end up spending
more in the long run but once you do it
right with t-shirts and boxers that feel
silky smooth from day one they will last
you for years to come you'll get 15 off
everything in their store at
davidpackman.com NYC the link is below
will Fox News host Steve Ducey is Off
Script again I have to tell you I really
do enjoy these clips these are Clips
were on the Fox News Morning Show Fox
and Friends Steve Ducey not because he's
a hero not because he's now the Arbiter
of Truth not because he's anything other
than a Fox News propagandist who
sometimes just interjects a little
reality into the brains of his co-host
for whatever reason Steve Ducey is
making some what in most of the real
world are uncontroversial admissions but
he's making them on Fox News and it's
fascinating to watch the latest one here
is Steve Ducey saying hey you know the
Biden economy actually is good I mean
okay the White House maybe is having a
messaging issue but the Biden economy
really seems to actually be functioning
quite well take a listen to this and
again he's touting the numbers that we
all see this is not
extraordinarily obscure stuff no and
that you have just touched on the the
problem for the White House and that is
they've got some pretty good numbers
going on right uh the jobs number is
expected to come out a little later on
today it's expected to be about 250 225
000 unemployment is expected to drop
down to 3.6 yesterday there was a
blowout number ADP said that about a
half a million jobs were added in June
the construction sector itself added 97
000 jobs
this is this is not Steve Ducey making
stuff up it's just not the place you
would normally hear it in June that's
the biggest increase month over month in
a decade so they've got these pretty
good numbers but the White House is
stuck with a couple of people who are
having a problem selling it because
people don't feel like things are very
good now uh and the clip of course from
our friend decoding Fox News who does
great work uh typically on Twitter now
also on threads you can find her
decoding Fox News on on threads as well
Steve Ducey is doing this a lot and I
don't want to attribute agency
to what might be Randomness this is you
know forget about right wing media but
there is so much scholarship and I've
read so much books that there's uh
Naseem talibs Fooled by Randomness and
Daniel Kahneman has written about this
in general as humans we like to find
patterns and and attribute agency to
phenomena in the world a really long
time ago but when when pre-modern humans
um started to see things move around in
the sky and the sun come up and go down
whatever
it would sometimes be attributed to a
man in the sky or some particular force
with agency rather than uh sort of the
way that uh the the laws of physics are
impacting celestial bodies so we we like
as humans to put agency and meaning and
whatever I can't do that with Steve
Ducey I don't know that what's happening
here is that Steve Ducey has said you
know my network is spreading a lot of
disinformation I'm going to go out there
and be the voice that tells a little bit
of the truth or something like I have no
reason to think that that is what is
going on but Steve Ducey has this habit
of saying things that go against the
talking points of Fox News here's one
other really good example this one's
from about a week and a half ago this
was related to the supposed there was
like a 72-hour period you might remember
where the Republicans became obsessed
with supposed evidence of Biden bribery
it turned out that it's based on tapes
they don't have from a whistleblower who
might not be a whistleblower who they
hadn't spoken to in three years who more
recently we've uncovered has never
actually spoken to Joe Biden so this one
evaporated quickly but here was Steve
Ducey sort of saying yet there really
isn't evidence here it is unclear what
the joint venture is or was uh and if it
was just for Biden corruption then why
did they have other entities like uh
they had they mentioned Hudson and some
other partners as well if it was just to
influence a former vice president which
I don't know if that's illegal uh why
exactly were there so many other moving
parts and what the Republicans don't do
here yet is they don't say uh if any
laws were broken and if anything was
illegal well what they are saying right
it's quite simple they've not actually
said what are the laws that were broken
and what is it that Joe Biden did that
is illegal make of it what you will let
me know in the comments what you do
think what is going on with Steve Ducey
the failed former president resident
twice impeached twice indicted twice
arrested is facing a nightmare scenario
related to Arizona because top
Republicans are now cooperating with
special prosecutor Jack Smith this is if
you were Trump and you were hoping that
the indictments and the arrests would
stop it too but then you saw okay so
like there's the riot thing from Jack
Smith okay I might face federal charges
okay there's also the Georgia thing from
fawnee Willis I might face State charges
there is now another scenario out of
Arizona Newsweek reports Trump faces
nightmare scenario as top Republicans
cooperate with Jack Smith former Arizona
house Speaker Rusty Bowers has become
the latest Republican to confirm they
were interviewed as part of the federal
investigation into attempts to overturn
the 2020 election Bowers previously
testified to the January 6 committee
that Trump and Rudy Giuliani called him
to discuss a plan to appoint fake
electoral officials to falsely declare
that Joe Biden was defeated in several
States this is per CNN according to what
this uh what Rusty Bowers told the FBI
this is a major deal this would confirm
if the testimony is trustworthy uh and
of course it was it was under oath this
would confirm
that this was not random people in
Arizona and Wisconsin and Georgia and
Michigan saying ah maybe we'll send some
fake electors and just say oh actually
it was uh it was Trump who won it was
Trump not not Joe Biden if indeed Trump
and Rudy Giuliani were on the phone with
Rusty Bowers the former Arizona House
speaker saying let's let's do this let's
find different electors and send them
and have them say I won this is rising
to a level of conspiracy
specifically in Arizona that we did not
previously know
um Christine Adams a former Federal
prosecutor and current partner with
Adams direct and caymanstein told
Newsweek that Bowers speaking with the
FBI shows Federal prosecutors are
conducting a thorough and careful
investigation across several States
could this lead to another series of
federal charges against Donald Trump and
potentially Rudy Giuliani sure could
this as we suggested last week be
opening up another wing of Investigation
related to State charges against Trump
in Arizona the answer is yes of course
this news suggests to us that it's not
just three potential indictments it's
not just four potential indictments that
Trump could be facing you are actually
talking about five or even potentially
six indictments state and federal
against Donald Trump this guy Rusty
Bowers is no hero
he is doing what most normal people
would do which is tell the truth as you
see it uh when authorities say you have
things we want to know and we don't hold
them up as a hero for doing it but we
say at least he's doing his basic Duty
which is these are very serious
allegations these are extraordinarily
serious uh unprecedented actions alleged
actions by a former president you show
up and you tell the truth you don't do
the Bannon thing you don't try to get
out of it you show up and you tell the
truth we'll see what happens but this
could be getting very very bad for
Donald Trump we're going to take a super
quick break Rosie O'Donnell joins me
next
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
well this is very exciting today we have
the great pleasure of being joined by
Rosie O'Donnell who who needs no
introduction and so I won't even really
do one Rosie I mean I think that that's
the most appropriate thing I think
you're totally right I love to say they
need no introduction but in 1990 you
know so so listen to start with where
were you when in the 2016 primaries
Trump starts insulting you did you see
that live or did someone tell you
Trump's talking about you right now
well it really started in 2007 when I
was on The View and he uh you know went
on like a 10-year or an eight-year
tirade and went on all the shows I think
he was very shocked that someone said
the truth about him on mainstream media
and uh he was determined to try to
destroy you know my credibility or my
um you know my who I am as a person by
doing these barrage of insults but I
think the one you're talking about was
with Megyn Kelly when she was yes and he
said you call women cows and pigs and
slobs and he says no only Rosie
O'Donnell right I was watching it live
you were watching it live and my kids
were in the room with me and they said
Mom what did he just say you I go yes he
did and he's not only insulting me he's
insulting any woman that he doesn't
think lives up to his standards of what
a woman is and that's the kind of person
that this this man is and why he's a
danger to the world and I knew that
innately from when I was you know
if you grew up on Long Island you knew
the story of Donald Trump he was not
some man that
um Mark Burnett made him out to be he
was given to America in a in a in a way
that that was a fallacy and I think that
that really stuck and that was the
beginning of the cultish like Dedication
that people have to the fantasy fiction
of The Apprentice and
um
but if you grow up on Long Island you
knew his story from when you were a
little kid you remembered his Planes
getting repossessed off the LaGuardia
runways you know you remembered every
time he had an embarrassing failure or
pretended to be his own publicist he was
known as this kind of joke of a person
and
um
when I took on telling the truth about
him uh he became obsessed and so even
though it seemed completely out of the
blue when he brought you up in that
situation with Megan Kelly you'd weren't
shocked because you you were aware of
the backstory
yes but it had been a few years before I
was the since I was the target he you
know chooses targets and keeps them for
a while and yeah and when he no longer
has use for them or you know so he
hadn't done it in a while but it was uh
um something that he had done for almost
a decade
on Tick Tock you if people have been
following you on Tick Tock they know
that you are very much following what is
going on politically but also
specifically with Donald Trump and
there's been this sense maybe over the
last three months that maybe there will
be some consequences at some point we
have two indictments there may be a
third one there may be a fourth one are
you optimistic or are you worried that
it's going to be again he uses donor
money to somehow slip out of this one
and that one and that this will all be
for nothing
in order to keep my faith in the nation
in the world I have to believe yes that
will have to pay for what he's done
inciting an Insurrection against our own
government he is the most horrific
president we've ever had the most
dangerous the most damaging to our
country and he's he's an embarrassment
and uh he always has been and I didn't
really understand that people
didn't get that and I really do blame
Mark Burnett I really do I know a lot of
people don't and think oh he was just
making no he knew who the man was he has
those tapes that he never showed of the
outtakes of The Apprentice where there
were many people there who have all told
their story of what language he uses of
what an innate racist he is misogynist
homophobic how he's like the worst part
of humanity and
um
you know I have been on to him from the
beginning and so have millions of people
across the world but especially New
Yorkers New Yorkers
see him for who he is
when you consider now what's going on
with this whole anti-woke Crusade that
some politicians are basically basing
their campaigns on Ron DeSantis for
example but then you actually talk to
people around the country and you say
hey do you actually think we're doing
too much to for example protect trans
people the majority of the country says
no actually I think we're actually not
doing enough we're doing the right
amount the the anti-woke message doesn't
seem to be panning out nationally and
one of the big targets for that group is
Hollywood Hollywood generally Hollywood
generically is propping up all of this
woke ideology if you're conservative in
Hollywood you're either blacklisted or
you get no work or whatever the case may
be can you talk a little bit about that
like is that assertion true or are there
plenty of conservatives in Hollywood
I don't really know that many
to tell you the God's honest truth but
you know
um Jewish liberals you know throughout
the history of Hollywood
the foundation of of Hollywood in in
many ways and
um I don't know that there's there are a
lot of let's say right-wing conservative
artists in general
right I don't think that when you look
for the pool of wearer is or are the
artists coming from and it's not going
to be the Harvard Business School right
so it's a different type of human it's a
different type of way of looking at the
world it's leading with Compassion or
leading with judgment thinking people
are expendable or that all people are
equal there's a big harsh divide in that
way so you know I mean Tom Selleck
pretty conservative
um Charlton Heston pretty conservative
but off the top of my head I can't
really think of very many people that I
know in Hollywood that are conservative
the anti-wolf message I think is a
ridiculous way to go and I hope DeSantis
keeps it up because he's like the worst
version of trump yeah it doesn't seem as
though it's going to play well
nationally like maybe it would win him a
Republican primary although it certainly
doesn't look like it if you look at the
polls but I just don't see how that
message resonates if he somehow were the
nominee I agree and and you know what
what does it mean to be woke it means to
be
um educated to be
[Music]
um
humanely centered and focused people
first equality first and those are
wonderful things and qualities of being
an American those are not negative
things that prove that you're not a
patriot you know liberals they they put
a Hollywood liberals you know Hollywood
liberals love their country too
Hollywood liberals grew up here and not
in uh affluent homes and you know the
people that I meet from Hollywood grew
up like I did Regular lower middle class
or middle class America where you know
blue collar workers or Engineers my dad
worked at Grumman you know and my mom
was a school secretary and
um that's kind of the truth of
of we we're American people uh I mean it
doesn't we're people who grew up
believing in the American dream and
somehow got there
and then to say everything that you feel
and think is invalid because you're a
celebrity
you lose your voice you lose your
speaking uh standard as a citizen you
become almost invalid because you are
known and I think the most important
thing right now is everyone with access
to a microphone to speak out against
fascism that really has still a strong
foothold here in the United States and
this election is going to be so very
important and I want to talk to you
about the nitty-gritty of the election
you know the patriotism thing is
interesting though the right has tried
to monopolize patriotism so when it was
George W bush in 2003 patriotism meant
you say it's great to go to Iraq even
though they didn't attack us on 9 11 and
this makes no sense whatsoever and they
don't have wmds that was patriotism then
under trumpet became a different thing
but the truth is that it seems to me
it's patriotic to say hey we're a
wealthy enough country that we can make
sure everybody has health care that's a
form of patriotism to me that makes a a
lot of sense and I wish the left would
take back the term to a in a more
forceful way I do too I feel that
um
there the the left some sometimes
buckles under the flag waving rhetoric
of of the right and I think we have just
as much love for our country as anyone
on their their side and at some point if
we are to survive as a nation we're
going to have to bridge the gap we're
going to have to find a way through that
Chasm you know over to each other and
and I don't know what it's going to take
to do that we're a different country
everyone has Niche news you know there
was when I was a kid and Walter Cronkite
said this war should end you know what
happened the war ended people believed
in him he wasn't owned by corporate
interests he wasn't trying to make a
profit news was not a profit-making
business when we were growing I was
growing up and I think that the mass
media especially the American Media news
let Trump get away with so much because
as
um you know moonves said not good for
America but great for CBS right
powerful thing to think but uh
yeah it's it's a very difficult time to
remain
steadfast in your belief that the ideals
of this country are worth fighting for
and
um we need to come together as as a
culture and as a a community and that
starts with holding Donald Trump
responsible for what he did uh and for
all of these charges against him I don't
know how you can look away and ignore 71
charges I don't indictments I don't know
how you can look away I I agree with you
um I mean so let's talk a little bit
about 2024 we'll get to Biden and I've
seen a little bit in preparing for this
conversation about the things you've
said about Joe Biden there is sort of a
Democratic Primary in the sense that
Bobby Kennedy Jr is running
he's polling about 15 which is not zero
I mean that's already something uh for
people who may or may not know your
backstory you were on Curb Your
Enthusiasm I know in 2011 although I
don't remember if you were on other
years Cheryl Hines an actress on that
show is married to Bobby Kennedy Jr
during the pandemic there was this crazy
thing where he was talking negatively
about vaccines she they had a holiday
party and she said you got to be
vaccinated to go to the party there was
this kind of interesting thing that was
going on now she supports his candidacy
what is your sense maybe having been
around her a little bit and seeing the
Dynamics of what's going on what is your
sense of this challenge to Joe Biden
that Bobby Kennedy Jr has mounted
you know I wish he didn't do it because
I think that any kind of third party
that's going to take away from the much
needed Democratic votes in order to stay
save the country from a fascist ideology
that we're already
um on the slope downward towards uh we
all have to stick together and I hope
that Bobby Kennedy would uh not do what
he's done now he has some pretty
controversial opinions he has some uh
conspiracy theories and and uh
you know I I think he's a danger in in
many ways to the outcome that I and
millions of others want which is the
Democrats to win and and I don't think
he has any chance of really winning
therefore uh why why do this at this
time in our history
when it comes to Biden I hope I'm
correctly summarizing your view which is
that you respect Joe Biden but would
rather he not run for re-election at
this time is that accurate
if I were a party uh a Democratic Party
uh you know if I was connected to the
Democratic party which I'm not I know
people might think oh you must no I
don't just me talking and
I think that his age is a problem I
think that there should be age limits
for how old you have to be to you have
to be 35 there should be an age limit at
the top as well and
um you know many of us at Thanksgiving
don't let our grandparents carve the
turkey
so I would have gotten together with all
the head honchos in the Democratic party
and said what is the best way that we
can win as a nation and continue the
amazing work that Joe Biden has done and
I'm thankful for him for saving us from
a second term of the worst president
ever I'm thankful for what he's done and
he's had really many more
accomplishments than most first-term
presidents so I have nothing but respect
and admiration for the work that he's
done in his life and career given his
entire career to public service
but I do inside of my soul wish that we
had a younger uh candidate that could
take the Baton and keep running the race
for us
um with that said I am riding with Biden
if that's the nominee I'm a hundred
percent going to back him but I do think
as a Democratic Party
they should really be sure that this is
the choice that
that will work best for the long run is
there somebody right now that you
actually find exciting
within the Democratic ranks someone that
I keep talking about is Gavin Newsom not
because he's perfect that's who I think
too not because he has no skeletons in
his closet not because he's the most
Progressive but he seems to understand
the sort of Ruthless attitude that is
required at this point to face off
against what the Republican party has
become
yes I agree I love when he gives
impromptu speeches to a reporter in the
street and he speaks from his heart and
he's not on script this man has a a
Charming continence and he is uh very
intelligent although he didn't marry
that Trump wife that's weird you know
when I think about that it's like yeah
he did the French Laundry dinner during
covet and that looked really bad but the
Kimberly Guilfoyle marriage is just very
strange to me me too like you know you
you don't want to judge people why God
knows I've been divorced twice I'm not
saying that uh but it makes me wonder it
gives me pause one of the things that
gives me pause about about him is that
and I think is that even fair that
that's what I but you know his wife now
is like unbelievable and so uh
intelligent and articulate and working
for the right causes and as an abuse
Survivor and I mean she's she's had
she's had some very impressive speeches
I've listened to her and um I believe in
Gavin Newsom I believe when he came out
and said no this is not right that gay
people cannot get married I'm going to
marry gay people and thanks to Gavin
newsom's courage you know I went and got
married right then on the steps and and
there and and uh we'll never forget the
what that meant to me and my family and
to so many others
um and why I thought it was very
important at that time to do it right I
felt like if you're gonna line people up
line me up I I will I want my equal
rights too uh you know so I I would go
with Gavin Newsom if it were me I would
push to sort of but no who's going to
say you know Gavin uh who's gonna nobody
should challenge
Joe Biden if Joe Biden isn't ready to
say that he's ready to go but I often
don't know when we get older if we
realize how different
we are in terms of our capacities
because you know it's I'm 61 and the
other day I couldn't think of Robert
Downey Jr's name I'm going come on he
played chaplain come on and I'm 61 right
so there are just real things about
aging that you know are concerning
although
I'm very grateful for Joe Biden last
thing I want to ask you about you
mentioned marriage equality over the
last couple of years obviously with the
overt transphobia and the focus at every
right wing event and Trump speech about
so-called men and women's sports and and
all of these things that are going on
certainly we've seen that there has been
this shift of scapegoating towards the
trans Community but even more broadly
than that do you think that some of the
progress that has been made culturally
not legally but culturally when it comes
to equality and respect and LGBT rights
do you think we've lost a little bit of
it in so far as when you see these
right-wing events lately they really
seem energized when the speakers say
something transphobic or homophobic at
CPAC the biggest Applause lines for Cruz
and Trump and others were when they
touched those topics standing ovations
people just loving it do you feel like
after a bunch of progress the last few
years has seen a little bit of of a loss
of ground
not a little bit a loss and we have
become the targets and when I say we I
mean all gay trans people well you know
the whole alphabet of it all of us
together right and if we don't stand
together while they attack the most
vulnerable of our people
one percent of the population and less
than one percent is trans
and those are the people that they're
going after it's very dangerous it's
very depressing and it's a a very
nazi-esque tactic and it should terrify
everyone we have made progress very much
so in my lifetime the concept as a
little girl who was 10 and knew she was
gay thinking that she could become a
famous entertainer and be there were
none that were out and get there was you
know maybe when I was 13 Elton John came
out and it was a big thing and who was
gonna still buy his records and you know
but I was raised on
a strong Foundation of feminism
and I am an Ardent feminist and I
believe that
women's equality gay equality minority
equality across the board all of us need
to get band together and and protect
Define and declare ourselves again the
concept that as a woman we are fighting
again for bodily autonomy
is enough to make you want to just you
know
I can't even believe that it's occurring
and I can't and this illegal scotus this
horrible
ridiculous scotus I don't know why Joe
Biden is against expanding the court I
have always felt like well uh you know
that's what you got to do when when
they're passing
decisions like they have been lately
yeah but yes as gay people we are
definitely in the Target and uh and it's
it's gone backwards in in a way that our
whole country seems to be lately and and
now the time is the time to stand strong
and arm and arm and know that we are
better than their ideals and their
misogyny and their bigotry yeah I can
assure you that if Trump or DeSantis win
in 24 we're not going in the right
direction that's for sure
for damn sure for damn sure but the
Republican party doesn't exist anymore
as it used to it's now nothing but uh
you know uh criminal Enterprise
which is is wreaking havoc on on the
nation
absolute last thing I've said that even
though I'm not a Republican and I'm not
voting in the Republican primary there's
very clearly one sane guy there and
that's Chris Christie and that I would
disagree with him I'm sure on policy in
so many different ways but he's at least
operating in the real world what what's
your view of the Republican primary
right now you know he is operating in
the real world but he was a trump kiss
ass yeah the Trump sass time and you
know that whole Brooklyn the George
Washington Bridge Escapade you know I
remember that too let's Picayune and
Petty and ridiculous and you don't want
somebody who thinks and acts that way in
in any kind of role of power but of all
the Republicans he is the one who is
speaking closest to the truth
um you know and I don't even I I kind of
find it David so shocking when
even on with with your podcast they talk
to Republicans and what they say they
think is the truth it's almost like a
delusional cult
deprogrammer is needed for the nation
with him
for the nation and I don't know how
we're ever going to get to that point
but the mountains and mountains of proof
don't move them
and I wonder what will yeah I don't have
the answer but we haven't found it yet
that that I can tell you
um Rosie thank you so much I really
appreciate your time and I'm just so
glad we were able to do this well me too
thank you I I am an Ardent uh follower
of yours thank you get up you do very
well David and I I follow Rosie on all
platforms please follow her as well
thank you so much thank you take care if
you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Donald
Trump gave two speeches over the weekend
one was in Nevada to some volunteers it
was ridiculous I'm not even going to
cover that but I do want to play a
couple of clips for you from Trump's
speech in Council Bluffs Iowa this one
was particularly glitchy and as you know
Donald Trump brain malfunctions often
during these events but it actually
seems to be getting even worse in this
clip you're going to say Donald Trump
you're going to hear Donald Trump say
that he will deny entry to the United
States to Communists which he said
before and I obviously he can't possibly
do it makes no sense almost certainly
illegal and impractical but he says I'm
going to deny entry to Communists and to
markers markers I think he means
marxists and he says they won't be
allowed into our cunni I I didn't
misspeak what I what I mean I did
misspeak but what I mean is Trump says
they won't be allowed into our cunni and
if you're watching you will see Trump do
that glitch he does when his brain
malfunctions it's very weird and it's
getting worse I will also order our
government to deny entry to all
Communists and markets look we have
marxists
fascists Communists they're pouring into
our country we are going to deny them
access to our country another one they
will not be allowed into our kunny it's
just not gonna happen not if Trump takes
our Connie back that's for damn sure so
that was the most visually ridiculous
moment but there were also some other
uh I don't want to say I felt bad but I
almost started thinking about maybe
considering the possibility of feeling
bad Trump's asked a question here he did
this thing where he takes questions from
the audience and it's always funny
and said he's asked a question about
something he has no idea about it's
related to farmland and pipelines Trump
very obviously has no clue what this
woman is talking about and he just kind
of says it's terrible isn't it well I
have a plan I have a plan no connection
to the subject matter whatsoever
yeah
well you know we're working on that and
you know we had a plan to totally uh
it's such a ridiculous situation isn't
it
we had a plan to totally to do what it's
ridiculous but we had a plan and we
would have instituted that plan and it
was already but uh we will get it but if
we win that's going to be taken care of
that will be one of the easy things we
do yep
um hey how will you fix this thing oh
well it's terrible what's going on we
had a plan if we win we're going to do
it very quickly and it's just horrible
what's going on with that but we have a
plan you know that don't you this is
what you say when you quite literally
have no idea what the subject matter is
that you're being asked about Trump then
made the false claim that in blue States
you can murder children
okay listen to this they are the
radicals not the pro-lifers they tried
to make the pro-life is a red no no when
they're willing to go into eight nine
ten months
after birth after birth that was a past
actually saying it's okay after birth
they are the radical ones and this is an
issue if properly spoken about it's uh
because nobody wants to see that it's
not happening it's not true that states
blue states have legalized killing
children after a period of time many
people right from the beginning but
nobody nobody wants to see after four
months five months six months
death termination nobody wants to see it
okay so Trump of course just lying about
the situation with abortion rights and
in fact abortion rights have been
curtailed uh dramatically as a result of
the overturning of Roe v Wade we're
already seeing it in a number of
different states and it's disgusting and
horrifying uh lastly Trump with a little
bit of projection he's talking about Joe
Biden but you'd think that this is
actually about Trump a man we have a
president of the United States who's a
stone cold corrupt Faith oh and
who's willing to arrest his opponent
okay of course Biden no involvement that
we know of with the arrest or indictment
of Donald Trump and if we want to talk
about corruption and criminality trumps
the guy who now has what 70 charges
against him in total across two
indictments so the typical sort of
greatest hits from Donald Trump
struggling to speak very low energy
speeches in front of small crowds the
campaign is getting going and as bad as
this is the question of course is can
anybody beat this guy in the Republican
party is there any appetite at all for
something different than this polling
suggests the answer is no we have new
polling we'll look at it tomorrow all
right I have incredibly good news and
Incredibly bad news about the children's
book I wrote about critical thinking you
know I joked last week
if someone tries to ban this book it
might actually be a great thing we now
are up against the first attempt to ban
the book and it's from a school library
I'll tell you about it in a moment so
here's the good of the book and of
course here's the copy of the book and
it's fantastic you can find it at
davidpackman.com book a lot of really
good things number one
4 200 copies have been ordered so far
that's 3 800 paperbacks and about 400
Kindle copies it seems with this book
about 90 percent of people want the
physical book for the kids
4 200 copies to 12 different countries
when we did this I thought it would be a
success if the book ever sold 500 copies
we're five days in and we've sold 4 200
copies incredible number one Amazon best
seller in multiple categories including
children's school and education books
this is the number one book on Amazon
for children's school and education
books I don't even know what I'm doing
to quote the failed former president
that's all great we're working on
getting the book on Barnes and Noble
it's not up to us Barnes and Noble is
announcing a major delay in approving
any new Authors for self-publishing I I
can't control it as soon as Barnes Noble
lets us on it will be available there
we're constantly releasing because we
can tweak the manuscript at any time
we're constantly making little tweaks
and finding small things to correct or
improve it's the same book it'll just
get a little more sophisticated over
time time but here's the bad we are now
seeing the first attempt to ban it I
heard from a I I can't tell if it's I
guess it is a librarian or a library
employee at a school in North Carolina
okay she's asking to be identified only
as bookie I like that she says the
following hey David I work in the school
library in North Carolina in a part of
the state that's more liberal but we
have lots of conservative parents from
the surrounding rural areas who bring
their kids to school I regularly buy new
books for the library and for the first
week we put them in a new book section
near the front door I got a copy of your
book and regularly see kids looking at
it I saw the I guess this means mothers
it's a there's a typo here but I believe
it means the mothers of two kids page
through it whisper to each other and
then tell me they want to file a
complaint about the book our school
thankfully hasn't been overrun by the
Maga crazies so there really isn't even
a complaint process for books so I told
them to talk to the principal or
superintendent they were indignant
saying you can just get whatever books
you want as the librarian
I explained that as the librarian that
is part of my job ordering books I
haven't heard anything since but I will
let you know what happens please keep my
name private and don't mention the
school but you can call me bookie in
North Carolina keep up the great work
okay she actually didn't even mention
her real name nor um nor what school
this is going on at so listen
somebody didn't like something and again
you know I got a couple complaints from
people saying David the kid that looks
like Trump in the book it's it
politicizes the book and now this is
this is the picture of the kid that
looks like Trump you shouldn't have done
that folks
you all know who I am you all know my
show this is it's just it's just a
picture of a kid that looks like Trump
it's part of the thing if it angers
conservatives then so be it Trump lies
about crowd sizes all the time that's
the kind of joke that's told in the book
it's really not a big deal let's all
relax so you can get the book at
davidpackman.com book very important
please leave a review we've sold 4 200
copies and there's only 80 reviews if we
could get three four five hundred
reviews it would just blow the book up
because so much of the recommendations
algorithm is based on reviews so forget
about if you've already bought the book
you that's great thank you
please make sure if you bought the book
that you review the book really
important
davidpackman.com book we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P here's a voicemail from someone
who says Brian Tyler Cohen is way hotter
than me
all right
hey uh sorry I think I have the right
number uh hey baby just wanted to say uh
I think you're really smoking full of
yourself and uh Brian Tyler thanks bye
all right thank you yep all right so the
the news there is I'm smug and full of
myself and Brian Tyler Cohen is way
hotter well listen call Brian and tell
him that I don't need you to call me all
right just leave me alone call all the
people who are hotter than me and tell
them I don't need you bringing me this
bad news we have a fantastic bonus show
today Joe Biden is defending the
decision to give cluster bombs to
Ukraine
not everybody likes that decision
Florida is Banning drivers licenses for
immigrants living in the United States
illegally even if they have a driver's
license and the FDA is being asked to
look at this Logan Paul energy drink
that has the caffeine of six Coke cans
this stuff is dangerous and we've
interviewed emergency room doctors about
it we'll talk about it on the bonus show
sign up for the bonus show at
joinpakman.com help us make a little
money on the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad yeah help us out you
can use the coupon code indicted again
join pacman.com bonus show commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show
it is all happening at joinpakman.com
we'll see you then we'll be back
tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it is hard to
find comfortable t-shirts shirts made of
supima cotton are the softest you will
find under one percent of t-shirts are
made with supima cotton and Leisure of
NYC is the place to find them you'll get
15 off their silky smooth t-shirts and
boxers at davidpackman.com
NYC the link is down below